a strong acid is an acid that ionizes
100 percent
in solution for example hydrochloric
acid hcl
is a strong acid it donates a proton to
water h2o
to form the hydronium ion h3o plus and
the conjugate base to hcl which is the
chloride anion cl minus
in reality this reaction reaches an
equilibrium however the equilibrium lies
so far to the right and favors the
product
so much that we don't draw an
equilibrium error we simply draw an
arrow going to the right
indicating the reaction essentially goes
to completion
and if the reaction essentially goes to
completion we can say that hydrochloric
acid ionizes 100 percent
and forms hydronium ions and chloride
anions
so essentially there's no more hcl left
it's all turned into h3o plus
and cl minus it's also acceptable to
completely leave
water out of the equation and to show a
hydrochloric acid hcl
turning into h plus and cl minus
once again since hcl is a strong acid
there's only an arrow going to the right
indicating hcl ionizes 100 percent
and since there's only one water
molecule difference between h
plus and h3o plus h plus and h3o plus
are used interchangeably
hydrochloric acid is an example of a
monoprotic strong acid
monoprotic means hydrochloric acid has
one proton that it can donate in
solution
other examples of monoprotic strong
acids include hydrobromic acid hbr
hydro iodic acid hi nitric acid
hno3 and perchloric acid hclo4
sulfuric acid is h2so4 and it's a strong
acid but it's a diprotic
acid meaning it has two protons that i
can donate
however only the first ionization for
sulfuric acid is strong
let's calculate the ph of a strong acid
solution
in this case we're going to do a 0.040
molar solution
of nitric acid nitric acid is hno3
and nitric acid reacts with water to
form hydronium h3o plus
and nitrate no3 minus which is the
conjugate base
2hno3 because nitric acid is a strong
acid we assume the reaction goes to
completion
therefore if the initial concentration
of nitric acid is point
zero four zero molar looking at our mole
ratios
in the balanced equation there's a one
in front of nitric acid and there's also
a one
in front of hydronium and a one in front
of nitrate
therefore if the reaction goes to
completion the concentration of
hydronium
would also be point zero four zero molar
and the same with the nitrate anion that
would also have a concentration of point
zero 0.040
molar since our goal is to calculate the
ph of this solution
we know that the equation for ph is ph
is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ions
therefore we just need to plug in the
concentration of hydronium ions into
our equation this gives us the ph is
equal to the negative
log of point zero four
zero which is equal to 1.40
so even though this is a pretty dilute
solution of nitric acid because nitric
acid is a strong acid
the ph is pretty low also note since we
have two significant figures for the
concentration of hydronium ions
we need two decimal places for our final
answer
let's do another problem with a strong
acid solution
let's say we have 100 milliliters of an
aqueous solution of hydro iodic acid and
the ph of the solution is equal to 1.50
and our goal is to find the mass of h i
that's present
in solution hydroionic acid reacts with
water to form the hydronium ion and the
iodide anion
and the mole ratio of hi to h3o plus
is one to one so if we can find the
concentration of hydronium ion in
solution
that should also be the concentration
the initial concentration of hydrobiotic
acid
and once we find the initial
concentration of hydrobiotic acid we can
find the mass of hi that's present
since we're given the ph in the problem
we can plug that directly into our
equation
which gives us 1.5
is equal to the negative log of the
concentration of hydronium ions
to solve for the concentration of
hydronium ions we can first move the
negative sign
to the left side which gives us negative
1.50
is equal to the log of the concentration
of hydronium ions
and to get rid of the log we can take 10
to both
sides so the concentration of hydronium
ions is equal to 10
to the negative 1.50 which is equal to
.032
so the concentration of hydronium ions
is 0.032
molar and because the mole ratio of
hydronium ion to h
i is one to one the initial
concentration of h i
is also .032
molar now that we know the initial
concentration of h
i we're ready to find the mass of h i
present
molarity is moles per liter so let's go
ahead and rewrite this
as .032
moles per liter the volume of the
solution
is 100 milliliters which is equal to
0.100 liters
so if we multiply moles per liter by the
volume which is 0.100 liters
liters will cancel and give us moles so
this is equal to
.0032
moles of hi since our goal is to find
the mass of hi
present the final step is to multiply
the moles of h i by the molar mass which
is
120 grams per
1 mole of h i so moles of h i would
cancel out
and this gives us 0.41 grams
as our final answer